it uh it sort of pains me to say this
because we've been saying for months we
need to be primarily led by doctors
about the virus not by politicians but
dr. deborah birx has become a primary
disseminator of laughable trumpian
propaganda and dr. Burks is no longer a
trustworthy source of information in
this entire thing it doesn't mean
everything she says is wrong but she is
no longer a trustworthy source overall
dr. deborah birx actually defended
Donald Trump's outrageous comment about
bleach injections as Trump talking out
loud and having dialogue in real time as
he synthesizes and assimilates data that
he has been presented now there is a
really important tell here in the video
I'm about to play for you that what dr.
Burks is saying is BS let's look at the
videos very shorts 25 seconds
see if you can pick out the tell that
dr. Burks is being dishonest
nobody gets new information he likes to
talk that through out loud and really
have that dialogue and so that's what
dialogue he was happy at having I think
he just saw the information at the time
immediately before the press conference
and he was still digesting that
information so the tale there that shows
us that dr. Burks is being dishonest is
that she had the idea to say oh Trump
had just seen this information for the
first time meaning a minute before he
made this crazy bleach comment but the
problem is that Donald Trump said during
the meeting during the briefing he had
already received this briefing about
disinfectants earlier in the day and as
dr. Burks is saying or about to say
Trump was reacting in real-time as he
learned about this she realizes wait a
second I can't say that because that
would contradict Trump Trump already
said during the briefing I got this
briefing earlier and I thought it was so
interesting I wanted it presented here
so in real time dr. Burks extends her
sentence and says I think he just saw
the information at the time pause
immediately before the press conference
check out that pause as dr. Burks
realizes oh wait a second I need to say
more
or this is going to be obviously a lie
and so that's what dialogue he was
happening at having I think he just saw
the information at the time immediately
before the press conference and he was
still digesting that information so she
is now a trump brown-noser she's
refusing to tell it like it is on
prematurely openings she resisted saying
that it was a concerning decision that
Florida made ten days ago to reopen
beaches or whenever it was and remember
that she also made this absolutely
insane claim a few weeks ago about how
Donald Trump just uses data to make
decisions and all of the stuff that we
simply know is not-- is is not true and
Trump has no attention span for how
would you describe the job president
Trump is doing behind the scenes and in
front of the cameras during these daily
briefings that we're seeing what's been
your perspective dr. Burks he's been so
attentive to the scientific literature
and the details and the data and I think
his his ability to analyze it integrate
data that comes out of his long history
in business has really been a real
benefit during these discussions about
medical issues because in the end data
is data and he understands the
importance of the granularity and I
think he's been really excited about
finding the level of detail that we've
been able to now bring over the last few
weeks to really understand who's at the
greatest risk for severe illness what
Trump is analyzing data at a granular
level to understand the details of this
pandemic that interview was back when
Trump had more recently said we have 15
cases and we will soon have zero this is
the Trump that last week wondered aloud
about injecting bleach and isopropyl
alcohol to treat coronavirus obviously
it's a lie Trump has been the opposite
of what dr. deborah birx claims so we've
talked before about a doctor making this
calculation that if they disagree with
from too much they get fired and if they
get fired they get replaced by some
total Trump sycophant and the country is
worth worse off doctor foul he made it
clear he said listen I can't jump in
front of the microphone
every single time Trump says something
and correct him it's just not feasible
but as you've seen doctor foul Qi
has been sidelined from the press
briefings for a while now dr. Burks has
gone fully into not just I won't
contradict Trump when he lies she's
starting to do this sort of sycophantic
stuff
that reminds me of Donald Trump's crazy
letter from his doctor saying Trump
would be the healthiest president ever
that's the type of disinformation that
dr. Burks is now a part of and it's
terrible because we are at a desperate
deficit of actual a trustworthy medical
professionals that our administration
adjacent unfortunately dr. Burks can no
longer be trusted and there are people
writing to me saying you know Burks has
Stockholm Syndrome she's starting to
side with her pack they're a captor I
don't know about that the only thing
that could be said is dr. Burks believes
that she can do more as a part of the
task force than not out than out of it
and she believes that she has to be
saying these things about Trump as
transparently unbelievable as they are
in order to remain on the task force
that's the most optimistic
interpretation of what dr. Burks has
been saying but to go on Christian
Broadcasting and say Trump synthesizes
data in this great way and other
transparently untrue things it seems
like it's overkill let me know what you
believe is going on with dr. Burks what
explains her behavior and also let me
know what you think is going on with dr.
fowey who's been missing from the press
briefings for more than a week now
despite Donald Trump every once in a
while alluding to or even saying
straight up oh yeah well you know don't
tony was part of the meeting earlier
what do you make of that I want to hear
from you and we will have continued
coverage of this and other stories from
today's program on the David Pakman show
Instagram page if you are on Instagram
you can do much worse than following at
David Pakman show on Instagram let me
tell you real quick about one of our
sponsors cuts clothing they offer super
quality men's t-shirts and they're
giving you 15% off when you go to david
pakman.com slash cuts that see UTS
because solid color t-shirt
are a really important staple in pretty
much every guy's wardrobe I think it's
really important not to overlook the
value of having t-shirts you love
wearing t-shirts from cuts clothing have
been a game changer for me and as a
company all they deal with are mens
solid color t-shirts so they actually
put a ton of thought into the comfort
the style the durability of the t-shirts
they make they fit perfectly they're not
scratchy they don't shrink they don't
fade they don't stretch out over time
like so many other t-shirts they're
really the most comfortable t-shirts
I've owned and they look great this
right here that I'm wearing on YouTube
is the split hem crew neck t-shirt very
soft fits me perfectly it's the ideal
length go take a look at what they offer
and once you have it you are really
going to see and feel the difference
their slogan is it's the only shirt
worth wearing you will see why and
you'll get 15% off when you do it by
going to david pakman.com slash cuts
that's david pakman.com slash c UTS